- Elle n
Ce n'est pas un pied cassé qui
allait echchcher Jane de venir
dormir dans cette petite tente
pour
"Pour êtrnnnnnnête, ce n'est
vraiment pas confortable.
Je n'ai pa
dernière. Je pensais le faire,
et puis cacacanards dans l'étang
se sont mis à cancaner."ttttttt,
aussi, est arrivée aussi
dès hier soir du Canada.
L'Albertaine ne manque aucuns ss
à Londres. "Il faut savoi
y faire", dit-elle.
"On n'est pas ici
que pour avoir l'air joli,
dit-elle, il faut être devant
et c'est ce qu'on fait.
de William et Kate et
Diana et Charles deux fois,
alors je sais comment m'y"""""""
L'anticipation ici
ce ne sont pas tous les Anglais
qui ont l'esprit à la fête.
Eugene Butcher n'a aucune
intention d'assister aux fêtes
du jubilé. S'il concède
souligner les 70 ans
gngngngngne de la monarque,
lui, ne le fera pas.
Pas s'il garde toute sa tête
♪ (punk) ♪
Le vieux punk a grandi
au son rebelle des Sex Pis
des Clash et des Ramones.
"Le climat social pourri de
méfiance de l'autorité
et des symboles", dit-il.
Un climat social qui ressemble
selon l'éditeur du magazine
"Vive le rock".
"Je suis fâché de voir
qu'on dépense 1 milliard de
livres, dit-il, pour célébrer
la reintntntntntntntntntntntntns
et que des gens, en ce moment,
doivent se rendre dans
les banques alimentaires
- Oh!
- Ce serait plutôt autour de
28 millions de livres sterling,
de dollars, qui sont dépensés
au cours des prochains
"Je pense qu'on a besoin
plus que jamais,
après les dernières années,
dit-elle, avec le confinement,
se rencontrer. Alors, j'espère
que ça va relever le moral
de la communauté et aider"""""""
Samantha Bowring est
Pour rassembler la population
autorararararararations,
la petite ville d'Abingdon
a
singulière de lancer
p p p p p p pains depuis
le toit de l'édifice municipal.
ainsi marquée par ces milliersis
sur la grande place.
- Oyez!lolololololololochette)
- Patrick Byrd et John Crowley
une autre traditiontout aussi a.
"Je n'ai connu que
le trône dans ma vie, dit-il.
Pour moi, elle représente
une brique dans un mur
Les deux hommes sont crie
Les naissances, les mariages,
les couronnements, les m d d d ,
c'est comme ça qu'il
annoncent.
- (ensemble): God
the Queen!
"Si ça vous plaît pas,
toujours regarder la télé.
Mais la plupart des gens adorent
la couleur, la cérémonie. C'est
c'est la tradition, c'est
la couleur. C'est une cérémonie
qu'on ne trouve nulle part
Rachel Crook, elle, contribue à
un phénomène tout aussi anglais,
quoique beaucoup plus récent.
sa passion pour le crochet à
son attachement pour la famille
royale. Elle a consacrémamamamai
un "topper", un bonnet l l l l .
Depuis quelque
il coiffe des boîtes
un p
"Il y a sans doute une forme
de d d d d d d d d d dit-elle,
et que les gens essaient
toujours plus grand et mieux."
e e e e e e e e e e Mall,
à Londres, quatrek k k k k k k r
un avant-goût de
est annoncé comme la parade
de toute une gbebebebebebebebeb,
est particul
(en anglais)
À 94 an
mieux que quiconque l'ampleuriq.
Le dernier du genre pour lui,
mais aussi pour sa pfafafafafaf,
croit-il. Le vieil hommepense q,
ce sera le début de la fin
pour la mona
"J'imagine qu'il faut savoir
passer autre chose", dit-il.
Mais il ne veut surtout pas
à la fête qu'il veut assister."
(chant)
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Canada,